l'électricité aux Madelinots,
et c'est la plus polluante
du Québec. Mais cette transition
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s se
des Îles. Le reportage
d'Elisa Serret.
- C'est un passage obligé
aux Îles-de-la-Maininine,
tout le monde le sait,
mais qui vient
- Il y a des choses...
des grosses quononons à se poser
parce que ça va toucher beaucoup
de monde.
- Moi, je suis inquiet
surtou c c c ceux qui viennent
en arrière de moi.
♪ ♪ ♪
qui attend la petite communauté:
anananansition énergétique.
Sur l'archipel, où nos yeux
sont constamment sol b b b b b ,
il y a aussi ce monstre :
une centrale thermique au mazout
qui alimente en électricité
au Québec, la plus polluante.
Maanananangements climatiques
obligent, Hydro-Québec
est forcé de
LOUIS-PHILIPPE BÉRUBÉ,
- Pour les Îles-de-la-Madeleine.
qui représentent le plus grand
réseau autonome d'Hydro-Québec,
solutions. Donc, qu'on parle
de raccordement, qu'on parle
de l'éolien, du solaire,
- La centrale au mazout faitrtrx
autonomes. À elle seule,
de toutes les émissions de
gaz à d d d d de serre produites
par Hydro-Québec en 2017.
La soluti
après consultations publiques :
un câble souse e e e e 225 km
qui relie la Gaspésie
à l'archipel, perme r r r r r rs
à la production d'énerg
aux Îles. Une option, qui,
selon Hydro-Québec, répondttttt.
- Donc on parle
de l'environnement, on parle
des coûts, de l'acceptabilitétéi
sont les quatre grands critères
qui guident la conversion
de nos réseaux autonomes.
de garder ses 82 employés,
entre autres parce qu'elle a
choisit de laisser en fonction
une centaine d'heures par année.
Une roue de secours en cas de
bris et un atout utile
- Hydro-Québec, effectivement,
gegegegegege à préserver le même
niveau d'emploi. La façon que
ça
encore statué, on va travailler
ça aveoyoyoyoyoyoyés, avec
les besoins d'Hydro-Québec. On a
aussi certqui émergent de la pa.
- Ce manque de p
laisse les employés comme
Pascal Lapierre perp L L L L L ,
chef machiniste Hydro-Québ
- Des inquiétudes, là, au niveau
des emplois. Hydro-Québec aisise
forme que ça va prendre puis
quelle... On va-tu devenir
des métiers qui vont passerbubuu
ou quoi que ce soit? Il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétude sur place
qui se fait ressentir.
par exemple, que son fils
mécanicien ne puisse lui
succéder à la centrale parce que
et bien payés sont des remparts.
- Tous les emplois qu'on peutci,
c'est sûr que ça... ça a
son importance, chaque emploi.
- Des craintes partagéesJoJoJoJ,
inquiet de voir les emplois
disparaître sournoisement
au fil des départs.THTHTHTHTHTH,
maire des Îles-de-la-Madeleine
une famille de moins aux Îles,
c'trtrtrtrtrtrtrtre deux enfants
de moins dans une école qui a
un ratio
le maintien de l'école ouverte
et la fermet........
- Et le changement risque
sur les emplois indirects.
- C'est tellement beau, hein,
les Îles!
la moitié des résidents des Îles
chauffent leur maison
avec une fournaise à l'huile.
par Hydro-Québec pour compenser
les carences de sa centrale.
Là, il y a quelqu'un qui vient
PATRICE THÉRIAULT,cheur madelint
- À chaque année, ils viennent
les choses, ils la mettent
r r r r r r r r r l'hiver.
- Un plombier,
un s
- Un sous-contractant qui vient
ici. C'eututututututututututes
les maisons des Îles qui ont
des fournaisfifififififififififa
fournaise à point
- Et lui, il est payé
par Hydro-Québec?r r r r r r r .
- Quand ça, ça va arrêter,
il n'aura plus son contrat.
- Bien non, il n'aura plus
perdus, là!
oioioioioioioioioiois perdus.
Ça vous inquiète?
- Ça m'inquiète beaucoup,
- Autre conséquence pour: : : :e
subventionné se traduira
par  une hausse de 30 %
- C'est un système qui est
beauteteteteteteteteteteux
présentement que ce qui va
s'en venir avec l'électricité.
- Près de la Pointe-aux-Loups
se dressent ces deux géantes
Érigées au début de l'été,
ces éoliennes comblent environ
10 % dplplplplplplplplplplplplpe
qu'aurait pu prendrensnsnsnsnsne
sur l'archipel avec un peu plus
d'audace et d'imagination,
- Nous ce qu'on proposait,
c'était plut
énergétique. Donc une mixité
de solutions qui auraient puchc,
on était dans l'univers des
possibles. C'est une question
de vision, c'est une questiones.
- Un rendez-vous manqué,
le dos aux énergies fossiles,
car, avec la solution
par Hydro-Québec, le monstre
est là pour rester.
♪ ♪ ♪